what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
yesterday we got the full official
trailer for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and it was
absolutely insane they actually revealed
professor x and the illuminati in the
first full trailer that we got for the
movie and you have to be wondering right
now if they revealed professor x in the
first trailer you can only imagine what
other cameos are coming now this trailer
is full of things that you need to know
and i broke it down into 15 different
parts that you have to know about this
upcoming movie no need to waste any time
let's dive into it if you love marvel
and want to stay up to date on the mcu
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos and doctor
strange videos all right so to start off
first things first they did release the
official poster for the movie yesterday
as well and it looks like deadpool has
been spotted in the poster and it looks
like they kind of hit him in a true
deadpool fashion as we see the glass
shattering that represents the
multiverse we can see a bunch of
different people inside different
shattered glass pieces and if we go up
to the upper left we can see a piece of
glass that kind of has a figure in it
although it is very well hidden but if
you enhance the photo there does appear
to be a very clear figure inside of this
glass piece and it's pretty recognizable
it looks like deadpool and he has his
finger over his mouth going shh
basically saying it's a secret that he's
in this trailer he's not supposed to be
noticed this is kind of him breaking the
fourth wall inside of a poster which i
think is brilliant and again talking
about cameos and going through different
universes all throughout the multiverse
seeing professor xavier and other
members of the illuminati it is totally
and completely possible that deadpool is
in this film and i'm guessing he
probably is what better way to get him
in the mcu whether it's permanently or
just temporarily at the moment now we'll
come back to this poster in a bit but
let's start with the trailer at the very
beginning doctor strange has a dream he
sees a desecrated sanctum standing alone
by itself and at his feet we can see
skeleton heads on the floor a lot of
them clearly a lot of people have died
here strange says every night he dreams
the same dream and then the nightmare
begins and he actually name drops
nightmare however i'm not sure they're
actually referring to the villain i do
think it's a little node towards the
villain and if nightmare is the villain
they are keeping him really under wraps
i think the villain of this film is
actually going to be a variant of doctor
strange and the scarlet witch i'm hoping
they keep it that way i'm sure there are
other sub villains of the movie like
gargantos who we see in this but i think
the main villain is the doctor strange
that we see at the end which we'll get
to but this dream since he's having it
over and over every night is most likely
not just a normal dream especially since
he sees america chavez being held
captive by a monster in his dream and he
also sees defender strange my guess is
that this is most likely a premonition
of what is to come or a doctor strange
from a different universe is trying to
warn him about what's to come to his
universe because it came to his already
and by his i mean the other variant now
nightmare was originally supposed to be
the villain for the first doctor strange
film and then he was supposed to be the
villain for this film however scott
derrickson is no longer directing the
film and sam raimi is so it looks like
that changed but like i said he still
could be the villain they just might be
keeping that a really big secret the
third thing that's really important
about this trailer is the scene where we
see doctor strange with these red orbs
now we've briefly seen this before in
the teaser but this adds two extra
scenes in it one where he is examining
the orb up close in his face and the
second where he seemingly slams all of
these orbs into a book now these orbs
are most likely created by wanda because
they're red which is most likely wanda's
chaos magic which is also why doctor
strange is examining them up close he
probably knows a little bit about chaos
magic but remember a scarlet witch isn't
really supposed to exist so this is
probably very concerning for him then
that book on the floor could be the
darkhold which is what wanda was
learning from the post-credit of one
division is where we saw wanda astral
projecting learning everything inside of
the darkhold the darkhold was created by
an ancient evil elder god so the magic
inside of it and the magic that you
would learn from it isn't exactly good
but this is the magic that wanda has
been learning so again it's probably
very concerning to strange which is why
he takes that magic and puts it back
inside of the book we then go back to
the same scene that we saw in the teaser
where doctor strange visits wanda and he
asks her what she knows about the
multiverse and here we get some new
dialogue wanda says viz had his theories
referring to vision of course and he
thought that it was dangerous in which
doctor strange replies he was right now
there are some really important things
we have to talk about right here because
i think this scene is a complete lie on
wanda's part not only did they release
this full trailer yesterday but they
also released a tv spot for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
which actually gave us some new footage
on top of this and that footage
seemingly revealed that this scene right
here is actually an illusion if we see
this scene from the tv spot we can tell
that this scene right here is actually
the same scene where wanda and doctor
strange are talking with all of the
white trees in the background in the
scene we can see the trees in the
background still and it does seem to be
the same shot of wanda and the same shot
of doctor strange they are in the exact
same positions now wanda may be learning
from the dark cold and she may be the
scarlet witch but doctor strange still
has a lot more knowledge because he's
had a lot more years to learn
specifically when it comes to actual
magic and spells so either here wanda
gets really upset with something that dr
strange says and reveals what is
actually going on around her or doctor
strange kind of says cut the crap i know
what's going on because i truly believe
that wanda does indeed know a lot about
the multiverse at this point in time
because in the post-credits scene when
she was learning about the dark cold and
learning new spells she heard the voice
of her kids she knows that they are
alive somewhere out there and she has
discovered the multiverse and knows that
she can go into a different universe and
find them so i think she's been studying
about the multiverse this entire time
and she's going to start to go through
different universes in order to find her
kids and get her family back and she
might even be looking for a different
version of vision as well he won't be
the same of course but he is an android
so maybe she could perhaps put his
memories back inside of his head and
this is where things get really really
intense we see mordo and we hear him say
i'm sorry steven but your desecration of
reality will not go unpunished doctor
strange is put into handcuffs some very
high-tech handcuffs and then we see
something that i have been talking about
for a very very long time we see doctor
strange being escorted by ultron bots
and i know that this is where everybody
including myself started to really freak
out these ultron bots are most likely
coming from a variant of iron man tony
stark probably superior iron man which
i'll talk about in just a bit but this
variant of iron man most likely got what
he wanted a suit of armor around the
world to protect the world or in this
case a suit of armor around the
multiverse and i actually think that the
mortar that we are seeing here is a
variant of mordo who is a part of the
illuminati which dr strange is about to
meet but this variant of tony stark
which i now have zero doubt that we'll
see and i actually think we do see him
in this trailer is the tony stark that
was successful at creating ultron and
putting his suits of armor ultron bots
around the world so the ultron bots kind
of arrest doctor strange and they take
him to what looks to be some type of
council he's taken into a room in which
we see six chairs and an open slot in
between the chairs and that's an
important slot which i'll talk about
this is the illuminati a multiversal
illuminati which if you've been
following the channel i've been talking
about this for a very long time because
it just made sense in the comics they
have an illuminati that is formed to
protect earth the illuminati is a
superhero group that was formed
consisting of all of the leaders of all
of the different superhero groups of
earth in the comics the group consists
of iron man representing the avengers mr
fantastic representing the fantastic
four namor the submariner representing
the atlanteans black bolt representing
the inhumans professor xavier
representing the mutants and dr strange
now we're probably not going to get that
exact lineup for the illuminati but
here's something very interesting that
is spotted in this scene in the comics
black panther was originally asked to
join the illuminati however he declined
but it doesn't look like he did in this
trailer because as doctor strange is
walking into the room and we see the six
chairs there we can see a figure sitting
in one of the chairs on the left and if
you pause it at just the right time you
can see a necklace around his neck
showing us that this is actually a
variant of black panther now this opens
up some really big questions that we
just don't know the answer to like did
chadwick boseman somehow film this scene
before he passed away i don't think
that's likely so i'm thinking that
there's going to be another actor that
is playing black panther unless they
decide to go with like killmonger here
but i'm guessing it's a variant of black
panther and i'm very curious who they
got to play this role so it looks like
black panther is one member of the
illuminati and like i mentioned this is
most likely a multiversal illuminati a
team that is not only responsible for
protecting their own planets but
responsible for protecting the entire
multiverse as a whole when one universe
or when one person from a universe gets
out of hand and starts affecting other
universes that's where the team jumps in
and tries to stop everything and in our
case we actually have two beings who are
affecting the multiverse we have doctor
strange and the scarlet witch so black
panther is one member it looks like
mordo is another member because there is
a figure that is walking in from the
right to the left to go sit down that
looks like mordo based off what we've
seen there is another figure sitting
down in a chair who does look very very
large this person is very hard to make
out we can't really tell who it is but
this person does look very very big
because if you look at the top of his
head and you compare it to black
panther's head on the left it's much
higher so perhaps this is an x-men of
some sort we'll have to wait and see but
there is one x-men who was introduced in
this scene like i mentioned there was a
space in between those chairs and it's
an important space because this person
does not need a chair because he has a
wheelchair and of course that person is
professor x doctor strange gets in the
room and professor xavier says we should
tell him the truth we should tell him
the truth now we know it's professor x
because this was a very distinguishable
voice it is clearly the voice of patrick
stewart and then we see this character
show up and this person doesn't just
show up it looks like they actually roll
up and we can see the outline silhouette
of them and it does look like patrick
stewart he's been rumored to be in this
film for a long time and they just
confirmed it instead of letting leagues
get out of hand they embraced this and
they showed it and again they showed
this so imagine what other characters
are going to be in this film now
obviously this part was amazing but
there still are a lot of other important
parts of this trailer so let's continue
it looks like a what if animated
universe crossover is indeed going to
happen and there's actually two signs of
this one is in the actual trailer we see
america chavez falling with doctor
strange we can see dinosaurs behind them
which i'll talk about in just a bit but
then we see a universe shatter and if
you look at the universe shattering we
can see a different world and it is an
animated world confirming that they will
at one point in time go into an animated
universe but there's even more proof of
this in the official poster that we got
for multiverse of mantis where we can
actually see peggy carter's shield
captain carter shield confirming that
she is going to be in the film which is
something that has been talked about for
a very very long time and it's now
confirmed now also in this scene we see
dinosaurs and comic book fans know
exactly what this is this is the savage
land a hidden prehistoric land that has
deep connections to professor xavier and
the x-men actually so professor x
probably isn't the only x-men that's
going to be joining us now i doubt
they'll stay in this land for a pretty
long time i'm sure it's just going to be
as they're going through a bunch of
different universes but still this is
going to be insanely cool to see
dinosaurs in the mcu not that we haven't
already seen like dragons and stuff but
still now after we see this scene where
we see the animated universe and the
savage land we see doctor strange and
america chavez falling doctor strange is
holding on to america chavez and then we
see his face kind of turn into blocks
now this really does look like the
scarlet witch part in the comics where
she says no more mutants now we don't
really have mutants in our universe in
the mcu so i don't think there's going
to be a no more mutants moment but i do
think that this is a little node to that
moment from the comics now the next
scene there's a lot of debate about this
scene right now a figure comes in and
starts fighting wanda we don't really
know who this figure is because it could
be one of a few people or it could
actually be a couple people that we are
seeing here now right off the bat i'm
sorry to disappoint i don't think this
is nova at all i know a lot of people
really wish it were him but i don't
think it is i think it's one of two
people or it could actually be two
separate people and i'll explain this at
first i definitely thought this is
captain marvel and i still do think it's
captain marvel but it's a variant of
captain marvel and this variant is maria
rambo she is coming from a universe
where everything that happened to carol
danvers her partner happened to her
instead and she's the one that became
captain marvel if you do a freeze frame
and a close-up here it really does look
like her however in the tv spot that was
released for multiverse of madness we
see this person in a different light
there's different footage that was not
shown in the trailer of this person and
this person actually kind of looks like
iron man in this scene it looks like
superior iron man and for a while now
tom cruise has been rumored to be
playing tony stark iron man in
multiverse of madness now of course he's
a variant but clearly since we see these
ultron bots here there is an iron man
that has perfected these bots and has
put a suit of armor around the world of
multiverse it would make sense that we
would actually see this variant of iron
man and i've been talking about patrick
stewart returning for a pretty long time
and since that ended up being true i
would not be surprised in the slightest
if tom cruise really is in the movie
playing iron man superior iron man to be
exact because if you zoom in on this one
it really does look like this person has
a goatee and a mustache just like tony
stark and here's my theory behind this
if this variant of tony stark did
perfect the ultron bots and did put a
suit of armor around the world he has
most likely perfected iron man suits as
well and seeing how this person is on
the illuminati it would make sense that
he would give his fellow illuminati
members suits why because these suits
could harness the power of infinity
stones they're essentially giant
infinity gauntlets instead of just a
gauntlet it's an entire suit essentially
it's what we thought and hoped we'd see
in avengers end game and in these two
different scenes here they really do
look like two different people one
really does look like maria rambo and
the other does really look like tony
stark now it could just be unfinished
cgi or it could be complete misdirection
by marvel but right now i think that
these are suits designed to fight some
of the most strongest beings in the
multiverse since that's what this
illuminati's job is to take out all of
these beings who threaten the multiverse
and we see them fighting the scarlet
witch we see them fight wanda or who
could be the variant of wanda because a
variant of wanda is introduced which
we'll get to in just a bit but the big
thing to notice here is that this fight
is actually happening in the
illuminati's headquarters as doctor
strange is being taken in to see the
illuminati we can see some statues of
people with wings in this scene here
where captain marvel or tony stark is
fighting wanda we can see the same
statue so this is wanda attacking the
illuminati or the illuminati attacking
her either way i don't think they're
gonna win i think wanda is going to beat
them now here we have a scene with
america chavez and gargantos and also
wang doctor strange and america chavez
are in the streets of new york we see
america java say look out and gargantos
attacks them now for those of you who
don't know america chavez has the power
to travel interdimensionally she can hop
between universes using star-shaped
portals that she can produce and i'm
thinking that this scene right here is
where she comes to our universe for the
very first time a leaked audition a
while ago kind of told us how america
chavez gets into the scene it says she
comes into our universe and a monster
was attacking her now this monster is
probably gargantos who is shown here so
this scene right here is probably the
first time that her and doctor strange
are meeting and from here she becomes an
ally of doctor strange now from here we
get into some really important things
specifically about the scarlet witch and
doctor strange and their variants now
this is where we get the dialogue from
wanda talking to doctor strange where
she says you break the rules and become
a hero when she says this we see an
alternate universe where there's a
statue of doctor strange in front of the
sanctum now what's really interesting
about this scene though with the statue
is that if you look you can see white
trees around the statue the same type of
trees that we see when doctor strange is
talking to wanda even though i do think
this could be an illusion which leads me
to believe that perhaps wanda could be
manipulating doctor strange a bit as
well making him see illusions but of
course there's always the possibility
that there is a universe where he is a
big hero and as far as the trees go
maybe they mean something or maybe
they're just pretty but wanda finishes
by saying i do it and i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair and this is where
we see the scarlet witch variant now in
the first what i believe to be the first
official poster released for doctor
strange and multiverse of madness by
marvel studios we can see very clearly
three versions of doctor strange and two
versions of wanda we see normal doctor
strange defender strange and who i'm
guessing is an evil sorcerer supreme
strange and then with wanda i'm assuming
it's our normal wanda but then an evil
one and i'll explain that right now
because the next scene that we get is
wanda covered in blood now if you look
at the background you can tell that this
is the illuminati headquarters which
leads me to believe this is after her
fight with whoever she's fighting in the
illuminati probably all of them but
based off of the way she is standing and
based on all the blood that she's
covered in it looks like she's won
whatever fight just took place yeah she
got roughed up because she's fighting
some of the most powerful characters in
the multiverse but she won and to me
this looks to be the finishing blow now
she's not in her scarlet witch outfit
which leads me to believe that this is
probably the variant because we see the
scarlet witch in her outfit a lot and
when we left wanda in one division she
was wearing the full scarlet witch
outfit so i think the one that comes in
wearing normal clothes is the evil one
but i think she's manipulating our wanda
perhaps telling her that they've taken
everything from us and we don't have to
listen to everybody because we are the
most powerful being in the entire
multiverse which is true i do fully
believe that she is probably going to
kill the entire illuminati now in the tv
spot that was released that had
different footage we actually see a
zombie wanda and a zombie doctor strange
and i don't think these are different
variants than we've already seen i think
they are variants going through
something i actually think maybe they
die and kind of get possessed and that's
how they become zombies after all like i
said the darkhold is made by an ancient
evil elder god and in fact wanda's body
was meant for that evil elder god to
possess at one point in time so he could
get back to the universe so i'm thinking
that at some point in time the two
variants of doctor strange and wanda the
evil ones actually do die and perhaps
become possessed possessed by demons or
some type of evil god and that's
actually what i think we are seeing in
this final scene where wong is yelling
strange and we see a very very dark
strange who seems to be possessed now a
lot of people were saying oh this is
null the creator of the symbiotes and
god of darkness but no it's not i think
this is just a possessed evil strange
and i think that this is who is going to
be the main villain of the movie along
with the evil wanda and last but not
least there is a scene in the tv spot
where wanda kind of shatters the
universe it actually looks like a scene
directly from marvel's what if with the
watcher where ultron chatters the
universe so clearly wanda has a ton of
power and is going to make for an
excellent villain alongside of doctor
strange and whatever else they're going
to throw at us in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness so let me know
what you think about the trailer in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news and
videos for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me